it has been an extraordinarily wet start
to july in western and central europe
in the netherlands 10 centimeters of
rain fell on the area around maastricht
in two days
more than the region would normally
expect over the whole of the summer
in luxembourg city the streets were
submerged after
80 litres of rain fell on every square
meter in just one day
and in west london thunderstorms dumped
4.8 centimeters of rain on monday
making it the wettest day since 1983.
so what's going on well the prolonged
rain has been caused by a low pressure
system that's moving across central
europe
nasa says there's also been a persistent
northward bulge in the polar jet stream
over scandinavia this year
that has resulted in record june
temperatures in helsinki in finland
and moscow the shift has also brought
tropical temperatures
to arctic siberia with satellite images
showing the surface in some spots
reached 48 degrees meanwhile the western
states in the usa
are suffering the second extreme heat
wave of the summer
with a temperature in the town of
stovepipe wells in california
not falling below 42 degrees overnight
the highest daily minimum ever recorded
in the northern hemisphere
we've seen heat waves you know right
across the world
in fact droughts in one location and
because they're all so much more intense
when we can see that the atmosphere is
energetic and possibly more energetic
than we're predicting it in our climate
models
and that's the thing that is really
worrying scientists at oxford
university's world weather attribution
unit have looked at the west coast heat
wave
in june that saw the canadian town of
litton reach 49.6 degrees
they say that was a one in one thousand
year event
made two degrees warmer by climate
change by the 2040s
global warming will have reached the
point where a similar heat wave
is likely to occur every 5 to 10 years
a hotter atmosphere is already bringing
more extreme weather
more often and it's only going to get
worse